We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21centri.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Salute, Tom. Kirifi Fattas.
我们得到了全球知名大学加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，该校致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、环境和教育领域最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加利福尼亚州乃至全球范围内合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该校促进所有生命生活质量的宗旨。了解更多信息请访问 21centri.ucdavis.edu。这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。向汤姆、基里菲·法塔斯致敬。
Let me start with this. The invented language of Esperanto has a flag, and it kicks ass. Green field, white canton in the upper left corner with a green 5-pointed star on it. I'd be on board because of the design of the flag alone. Seriously, I could march in the streets behind that flag, but that's not the Esperanto way at all. Esperanto is about hope. It was created in the 1880s by Polish eye-doctor named Lud Saminhof, and he lived in this town Bialystok, where there were Poles, Jews, Germans, and Russians, and they all spoke different languages,
让我从这个开始。人造语言世界语有一面旗帜，而且非常酷。绿色的底色，左上角是一个白色的方形区域，上面有一颗绿色的五角星。单凭这面旗帜的设计，我就会加入。说真的，我可以举着这面旗帜在街头游行，但这绝不是世界语的方式。世界语关乎希望。它是由一位名叫路德维希·柴门霍夫的波兰眼科医生在 19世纪 80 年代创造的，他住在比亚韦斯托克这个小镇上，那里有波兰人、犹太人、德国人和俄罗斯人，他们都说不同的语言，
and they all hated each other. So he had this idea that if everybody spoke a common language, they could communicate, they could get to know each other as people, and there wouldn't be any more racism or conflict, which is a beautiful idea. This is Sam Green. My name is Sam Green, I'm the director of Utopia in the Four Movements. One of the four movements of Sam Green's live documentary is about the Zemanhoff's Utopia
而且他们都互相仇恨。所以他有一个想法：如果每个人都说一种共同的语言，他们就能沟通，就能作为人去了解彼此，就不会再有种族主义或冲突，这是一个美好的想法。这是萨姆·格林。我叫萨姆·格林，我是《乌托邦四乐章》的导演。萨姆·格林这部现场纪录片四个乐章中的一个，讲述的就是柴门霍夫的乌托邦——
of Esperanto. In some ways, the history of Esperanto really mirrors the 20th century in a certain flowering of Utopian energy and ultimate waning of that by the end of this century. Zemmanov's full dream of peace through a shared second language never came to pass. According to estimates, somewhere between 50,000 and 2 million people speak Esperanto. But that shouldn't suggest that Esperanto is a failure. In the history of invented languages, it's the greatest success story ever. Guess number two, Erica Okrent.
世界语。在某种程度上，世界语的历史确实映射了 20 世纪乌托邦能量的某种蓬勃发展，以及在这个世纪末期这种能量的最终衰落。柴门霍夫通过共同的第二语言来实现和平的完整梦想从未实现。据估计，有 5 万到 200 万人说世界语。但这并不意味着世界语是失败的。在人造语言的历史中，它是史上最伟大的成功故事。第二位嘉宾，埃里卡·奥克兰特。
My name is Erica Okrent, and I'm the author of In the Land of Invented Languages. Esperanto was a real product of the time. In the end of the 19th century, early 20th century, when nationalism was tearing Europe apart, all these old empires were crumbling, and the lines around which they fractured were linguistic ones. So it made a lot of sense to say, hey, let's find a linguistic solution to our problems. But the mantle of Esperanto as the king of invented languages also had to do with its design as a language.
我叫埃里卡·奥克兰特，我是《人造语言之乡》的作者。世界语是时代的真正产物。在 19世纪末、20世纪初，当民族主义将欧洲撕裂，所有这些旧帝国都在崩溃，它们分裂的界限正是语言的界限。所以，提出寻找一个语言上的解决方案来解决我们的问题，是非常合乎逻辑的。但是，世界语作为人造语言之王的地位，也与其作为一种语言的设计密不可分。
Well, Esperanto was designed to have as simple as possible a grammar, all nouns and an O, all adjectives and an A. Verb 10 is indicated by regular endings, and it never varies, so there are no irregular verbs. So you learn a finite number of endings and a few root words, and you're up and running. After a few weeks of learning Esperanto, you can start communicating meaningfully with other speakers. But its other strength is that it's not too engineered. Being over designed is a pitfall of many other invented languages. Previous projects tried to be so consistent and regular
嗯，世界语的设计旨在拥有尽可能简单的语法，所有名词都以 O 结尾，所有形容词都以 A 结尾。动词时态由规则词尾表示，而且从不改变，所以没有不规则动词。因此，你只需要学习有限数量的词尾和几个词根，就可以上手了。学习世界语几周后，你就可以开始与其他说话者进行有意义的交流。但它的另一个优势是它没有被过度设计。过度设计是许多其他人造语言的陷阱。先前的项目试图做到如此一致和规则，
and break down the entire world of concepts into their component pieces. Each letter would contain a part of meaning within it. Those kind of languages are impossible to use. Esperanto has this nice, sloppy middle ground. It's a nice balance between systematicity and arbitrary sloppiness. And when it comes to language, we need both of those things. In our natural languages, we need a way to get more specific when we need to, so we have stuff like legal jargon. But it also lets us just sort of talk without necessarily knowing where we're going with it, or knowing exactly what we need.
并把整个概念世界分解成它们的组成部分。每个字母都包含其内部的一部分含义。那种语言是无法使用的。世界语有一个很好、很随意的中间地带。它是系统性和任意随意性之间的一个很好的平衡。当谈到语言时，我们需要这两样东西。在我们的自然语言中，我们需要一种在需要时变得更具体的方法，所以我们有诸如法律术语之类的事物。但它也让我们能够随性地交谈，而不必一定知道我们要去哪里，或者确切知道我们需要什么。
So for all you language inventors out there, don't make it too perfect. A little fuzziness is key. out there don't make it too perfect. A little fuzziness is key. So is artistic expression. From the beginning, Zelenhof stressed poetry and music in Esperanto, and there are unique aspects to the language that make it especially suited to a kind of poetic wordplay. With endings you can make any word into a verb. So if you have blue-a meaning blue you can also have a verb. The blue-a is blue-ing. So an Esperantist can say La Cielo, Espa's blue-a. The sky is blue. But if you really want to be an Esperantist about it he'll say La Cielo, Blue-a.
所以对于你们所有语言发明者来说，不要把它做得太完美。一点模糊性是关键。艺术表达也是如此。从一开始，柴门霍夫就在世界语中强调诗歌和音乐，语言中有一些独特的方面使其特别适合某种诗意的文字游戏。通过词尾，你可以把任何词变成动词。所以如果你有表示“蓝色”的 blue-a，你也可以有一个动词。blue-a 就是在变蓝。所以一个世界语者可以说 La Cielo, Espa's blue-a。天空是蓝色的。但如果你真的想表现得像个世界语者，他会说 La Cielo, Blue-a。
The sky is blue-ing. And that's a very Esperanto way of expressing it. Any word can also be an adverb, which is strange, not many languages have this feature. So you don't say, I go to the beach in the summer, you will say, you know, summerally, I go to the beach. Summerally, I go to the beach. If you do not approve of that sense, I don't want to live in your dark and joyless little world. One of the ultimate ironies of Esperanto is that one of its most widespread uses in the US was during the Cold War. The US would do these war games against a fictitious enemy, the maneuver enemy, also known as the aggressor. And they'd have to have the enemy speaking
天空正在变蓝。这是一种非常世界语的表达方式。任何词也可以是副词，这很奇怪，没有多少语言有这个特征。所以你不会说，我夏天去海滩，你会说，你知道的，夏天般地，我去海滩。夏天般地，我去海滩。如果你不赞同这种感觉，我才不想活在你那个黑暗且毫无乐趣的小世界里。世界语的最终讽刺之一是，它在美国最广泛的用途之一是在冷战期间。美国会针对一个虚构的敌人进行这些战争游戏，这个机动敌人也被称为侵略者。他们必须让敌人说
a different language. And since they didn't want to offend any other country, they couldn't have them speaking Spanish or French. Russian even, they had them speaking Esperanto. Esperanto was used by the US Army, so it wouldn't possibly offend another country and cause some unnecessary conflict. So even in this distinctly American completely twisted context, as Buranto achieved exactly what it was designed to do. 99% Invisible was produced by me Roman Mars with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architect San Francisco and the Center for Architecture
一种不同的语言。由于他们不想冒犯任何其他国家，他们不能让他们说西班牙语或法语。甚至俄语，他们让他们说世界语。世界语被美国陆军使用，这样它就不会可能冒犯另一个国家并引起不必要的冲突。因此，即使在这个明显的美国式完全扭曲的背景下，世界语完全达到了它的设计目的。99% Invisible 由我罗曼·马尔斯制作，并得到了 Lunar 的支持，用创造力改变世界。它是 KALW、美国建筑师协会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。
and Design. To find out more, and see the flag of Esperanto, what you really should do, go to 99%invisible.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要了解更多信息并查看世界语的旗帜，你真正应该做的是访问 99%invisible.org。这个单集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。